I have chosen to do this by graphing
because I think graphic enforcement I
will show you this way and then I'll
show you how you can do it if you didn't
like wrapping which I take it a lot ok 1
over 2x minus 1 that is hyperbola here
okay that's what look like I want to
know where is the hyperbola below below
to that's what mean or equal to right so
what I do is I just grasp the hyperbola
I put in my two line see there it is
there's two and I want everything below
it or touching okay so you can just
barely barely make out you see how I
highlight this part Y bar how is it it's
below check whether this part here also
going to so those are the parts I want
therefore I'm going to work out the
x-rays and correspondence now now even
if you don't like Grampy you should be
able to look at this guy over here and
pretty quickly tell me what the vertical
axis to do you see where I love this job
where I get the top good yeah this is
the value that makes the denominator 0
which breaks my function that's what
gives me a vertical answer
so therefore to the left of that that's
all good that's all underneath too
and then I need to work out this point
of intersection which is exactly what I
did over there on the right hand side
okay once I know where everything's
happening absolutely
now I understand maybe not comfortable
with wrapping a traveller's that much to
which I was head two things number one
I've got another way to do it number two
you'd better get more comfortable
graphing is because they're not that bad
everything about that Keynes how you
would do it if you didn't want to use
her pose okay now have a look you've got
a note a few things and you can see by
the way why I like graphing because this
wine is fine it's just long as okay and
there's lots of places to just
numerically stuff itself on which in
fact I did the first time I saw okay
first thing let's start off here I've
written this down and immediately I
notice there is a domain restriction
okay I say that now because I don't have
a graph that tells me that's the case
so therefore advented notices to be do
now this next one here does something a
little bit weird can you see I've
multiplied both sides by two X minus one
squared now I know I'm looking at this
it's not obvious that you should
multiply by two X minus one squared
it's more obvious to multiply just like
2x minus 1 can someone tell me why I
can't do that yes
you don't know so there is this
restriction issue so that's a bit of a
problem but there's actually something
else which is a bigger issue
yes I'm Daniella okay very good so it
seems like there is I need I've
multiplied through by 2 X minus 1 and
that inequality sign is still facing the
same direction because why would our
changes and the answer is well what why
do I change the direction of the numbers
in what circumstances when the
denominator when whatever I x is
negative if you want to play both sides
or something like this 3 is less than 4
you multiply by negative 1 negative 3 is
not less than negative 4 negative 3 is
greater than negative 4 so negative
numbers switch the direction et is 30
and here's the dangerous thing about 2x
minus 1 you don't know whether it's
positive or negative the whole point of
having a permanent is that they can
change they can vary so sometimes
positive sometimes negative so what you
could do if you wanted was you could
save it but you would have to say it
indicate make or take one when 2x minus
1 is positive that's what you get and if
there's another case where 2 times 1
even positive and then you get the other
side but I'm going to do everything I
possibly can to avoid avoid cages
because this limit if there's my
solution is I multiply by the square why
is that a better option get close the
square we don't this before square
that's positive what you get with real
numbers anyway so I can leave my
inequality signs based in the direction
he's doing and he's not the trick once
you've done that you get some
simplifying your quadratic on the right
hand side once you tie your help your
factor on it and then you get to this
point here now please
you get to this quadratic in your
factorize it and I mix myself okay I
know what this looks like there are two
roots can you tell me what the result
from this you get a half and from this
you get three quarters you okay so I'm
just going to grow this to the hardware
and three quarters here so this is a
really awful problem to choose local
slices okay now your
this line here that are highlighted see
said tell me which parts of that
parabola are a bomb or equal to zero
right so in other words back solids can
choose another color that's this part
over here that part's good and this pile
over here that plays also group so
that's exactly what I've written here to
the left of us and to the right of 3/4
except remember the very first line I
noticed there was a domain restriction
remember that and that domain
restriction directly interact with the
inequalities use it so I was like oh
yeah actually actually less than or
equal to ha except I've got to pick out
that boundary so that's why there is
subtle change which students often this
when they sold it through this message
the graph is fine work quite nicely
actually
but you've got to up the other than I
did now I didn't worry about this on top
of a per client can you remember why I
didn't even have to worry about because
come back look there we go
because what what do you think equals
1/2 it's an absence of you can't touch
it right might be she tells me I can
touch screen so X have to be left and a
half as I've written over here because
you don't get to the boundary whereas X
is greater than or equal to 3/4 could
look at that point did you get the
matter does that make sense so whichever
you choose I'm fine happy if you did
either way but your monster there's
quite a lot of new ones to do it so I'd
expect every word like three months a
couple of months for those batteries and
gave direction to the inequalities and
then there's a whole life
or whether you understand that boundary
values on excluded okay question yeah
you're right so is good so for us so
let's just quickly pop that gem what's
the most important um another line there
zero sum and shutdown in our the easing
why don't you have a decent scale so if
I've port is one there half is exactly
halfway there's three quarters and now
that means a hollow let's choose a
different column I've got a hollow
circle there yes to the left and then
I've got a filled circle here looks cool
no spots there to the right happy that's
the better solution TV services picked
up a little yeah just a quick question
get us like chuckle you have
come up the right one that's a great
question
why is it that I have a high public year
with a barbecue and then when I fold it
the other way the intended method
I had a parabola balcony shape do you
remember this morning we were looking at
solar equations but some of them were
quadratics in disguise remember that
okay
but they are connected problems like
forming one in the instruments in
solving the other when you're solving
this sorry we are solving this you get
two regions which is exactly the same
and if you are solving a quadratic you
get to meet so that's why they actually
end up being equivalent problem if you
must want you buy a square of 2 H minus
1